Can a man shake hands with a woman while
wearing gloves? Please answer as soon as
possible. The question posed is that it
is prohibited in Islam for a man to
touch and he agrees with it. It's haram.
But can he touch a woman after wearing
gloves? Means if you're wearing gloves,
can he shake hands with a woman? And we
know the hadith of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is very clear
that the prophet peace be upon him said
it is better to hammer a nail or a
needle into the head rather than touch
an hammer. The hadith is very strong.
It's very bold. It's very direct. It is
preferable to hammer a nail or a needle
in the head rather than touch a woman.
So therefore touching nam is completely
haram. It is prohibited and not
permitted. There are a question that can
you touch a woman wearing gloves. Now
there are some hadith in which the
prophet is said to have shaken hands of
ladies beneath a cloth. There are a few
hadith but all these hadith is they are
weak. There is no authentic hadith in
which the prophet ever shook hands with
ladies. In fact there are various hadith
of may Allah be pleased with her who the
wife of the prophet say that the prophet
in his life has never touched any woman.
So based on this it is not permitted to
shake hands with women neither is it
permitted to shake hands wearing a
glove because yet even if you wear a
glove and shake hands of course it's
haram. There going to be feelings. You
cannot say nothing happening to you. So
it's not permitted to shake hand with
glove or without glove. Both are
prohibited. Hope that answers the
question.